carly in michigan you're on the bench go
for carly
hi um i was laid off back on
april 11th due to our governor's order
for lockdown
with the understanding that everybody
here was eligible for unemployment
however that's not the case and i'm just
wondering how it is legal
to force people out of work
that have zero savings especially in the
state
and expect them just to continue to pay
their mortgage their rent
their car payments their insurance their
food and yet if they try to get a job
somewhere
unless it's essential whatever their
definition
is of that anymore because that seems to
change
we are legally responsible so we'll end
up getting arrested or getting in
trouble how is this legal
i mean honestly i think it's it it's
nearly impossible to enforce
and and i think that you're going to
start seeing over time the governor's
basically acknowledged that it's
impossible to enforce i mean
the more stories that you see like the
story out of texas with this salon owner
who's now being hauled up and being told
that she needs to apologize and never go
to work until the government says she
can go to work and her saying listen i
can't feed my kids wow
the money didn't come through i can't
feed my kids the american people are not
going to stand for this kind of stuff
and the media have been utterly derelict
in their coverage of this utterly
derelict they've been suggesting that
there is no cost on the other side of
the ledger that the only thing we're
attempting to do here is save human
lives and that if you mention the
economic cost that that means that you
you all you're really worried about is
being able to get a haircut or go out to
dinner
no that's not what anybody is talking
about we're talking about people losing
their life savings we're talking about
people losing their homes we're talking
about people who can't feed their kids
or having to go to food banks and the
media have been
pretending that if you even mention
these things it's because you do not
care about human life it's ut honestly
it's utterly disgusting
it's it's truly disgusting because every
public policy is a matter of balance and
to pretend that there is no other
countervailing balance other than the
broad scale economy if you say the word
economy
it means that you're a bad person it's
just absurd the economy is regular
people who have lives
who have children who had jobs until
five minutes ago
and for the government to throw you out
of a job and then suggest okay well
we'll pay you but maybe we won't
you know maybe maybe the check will
never come or to tell people
that stay home until we tell you it's
okay to leave but we're never going to
give you a clear standard on when it's
okay to leave or how long you can leave
or
even if you do leave how you can run
your business like none of this is
sustainable on
any level carly and i i literally cannot
imagine this continuing
more than the next few days let alone
months i mean if they really think that
we're gonna shut this thing down all the
way until the end of the year until
vaccine is discovered
you're out of your damn mind this this
this is not this is not this cannot
continue it just cannot continue
and carly i don't know what what is your
situation in michigan with regard to
getting unemployment insurance my
understanding was that if you were
if you were unemployed and that if you
didn't fall into a group where you are
categorized as a dependent on somebody
else
then you should be able to get
unemployment insurance if you're
categorized as dependent on your parents
irs forms because you're 25 and in
college or something then
you can't get any sort of of
unemployment insurance on your own
benefit your parents can get
unemployment
but i don't know what category you fall
into that you're having trouble with the
government
there are a large number of people in
the state who have been denied
unemployment because they are going back
on
past employment in the past 18 months so
if you have ever
quit a job in the past 18 months prior
to being laid off
due to covid you are not eligible for
unemployment
so good luck to you i mean that that is
that is utterly insane that is utterly
insane obviously
and by the way so are a lot of the
government standards here the government
has
set standards they they were attempting
to basically
cut off particular businesses based on
size how many people
work for those businesses and those
businesses are trying to keep those
people paid
if you're a big business then then you
are cut off from the loan program
or if you're a publicly traded business
then you're cut off from the loan
program
look the reality is that the worse the
government makes this the less time it's
going to last because
the american people are just not going
to stand for it at a certain point
they're going to say listen i understand
this is gonna get bad
i also understand that you guys have no
solution i was talking about this
wharton model that talks about how many
deaths there are supposed to be
if if you just release everybody
willy-nilly by the end of june and the
numbers are terrible it's like 360
000 people 350 000 people as opposed to
the 117 000 people
if you maintain under lockdown through
the end of june but again it depends on
the timeline
if there is no cure if there is no
therapeutic the same number of people
are going to die it's just going to be a
matter of how long it is until the same
number of people die
and that that answer will be months not
years and then the question becomes okay
if the same number of people died
and it took and it took ten months as
opposed to taking three months until we
reached herd immunity
and we completely destroyed
40 million 50 million 100 million lives
in the process
is that a trade-off that was worth
making when when the death numbers look
exactly the same at the end of that
timeline
nobody is willing to have these
conversations because they would they
would actually militate
in favor of taking more reopening
provisions
in favor of reopening more but nobody
wants to do that because it's easier for
the media to sit atop their
their perch with their guaranteed
salaries and tell you that everything is
going to be fine
now a lot of people know that that
things are not going to be fine not the
way things are going i appreciate the
call carly hang in there grace in
massachusetts you're on the bench
pressure go for grace
hi ben what actions do you think the
united states should take against china
for releasing the virus
so there are a bunch of actions that
have been suggested including measures
that would basically force manufacturing
chains to relocate outside of china
depending on the industry that makes a
lot of sense if you're talking about
t-shirts doesn't make tons of sense
but if you're talking about vital
industries that cannot be put at risk
right industries like the medical supply
industry drug industries
you know defense industries that makes
perfect sense there's also been talk on
continuing
travel ban from china that makes perfect
sense to me as well as long as they're
going to allow these wet markets to
continue to exist so long as we have no
transparency into how their labs handle
things
it makes sense to me that we shouldn't
allow people to travel from there
that would include presumably student
visas and people attempting to come to
the united states
and get a degree at our at our
institutions and then go back home
to china right china is a security
threat it is a security threat
and what's what's hilarious that china
understands this
china understands that that that things
are about to get very rough there's an
editorial actually
in the south in the south china morning
post which is an official newspaper of
the communist chinese party
suggesting that if the us gets really
really antagonistic
then we could end up in a cold war
realistically speaking we've been in
cold war with china for quite a while
they've been stealing our intellectual
property
they've been using their built-in road
programs in order to set up
situations with governments that that
they can twist to be more unfriendly to
the united states
china is a bad actor and treating them
as a bad actor is absolutely necessary
grace i appreciate the call
lands in santa cruz california you're on
the bench period show fort lance
hey ben i was wondering what the dnc
would have to go through
in order to switch their presidential
bid and if they were to do that who do
you think they would choose
so in order for them to to throw in
order for them to throw biden out
right now biden does not actually have a
majority of the delegates because there
is no majority of the delegates meaning
a bunch of primaries are not going to
take place so he's just assumed to be
the nominee there's a world where
there's a move at the convention to get
delegates to switch
or you just say that they're a bunch of
unpledged delegates there is no majority
they go into a smoke-filled room and
they come out the other end
and say we decided against joe biden
realistically speaking
that is not something that is going to
happen joe biden is going to be the
nominee barring
some sort of of serious medical
condition that is revealed before the
election so
he's not going to be replaced if if he
were to be replaced then you would
assume that he would be replaced at this
point
with one of the governors of the states
that the media have made popular despite
their complete butchery whether it's
whether it's whitmer or cuomo cuomo
obviously gets all the press because the
media are all located
in new york even though cuomo has been
truly garbage at his job
appreciate the call
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content